来各位同学大家晚安
那正好大家在聊到那个小娜
我们就先来直接来聊一下
我今天就刚好今天做的小娜
有没有看到我今天早上
完全错过一大早的喷出
一单都没有
不管怎么喷我就是完全错过
第一段第二段都没有
而且都喷很远耶
然后
然后所以后来回来这边其实心里面我知道
那个
我知道那个时候是中午时间可能是冷门时段行情不见得容易出去
但是就有一个那个心
来所以故意看
各位看一下看一下我这边其实也没有赔到多少钱我们看一下
在这个地方
你看我用多少三口微型
去测试它 有没有
这画面圣诞树吗?没有哦 你等下慢慢看
我们仔细看一下 三口微型打平的打掉
不对 这个应该是 仔细看 三口微型 小亏
亏了以后 看行情好像回来到这里
这里大概在2点多
2点多想 又有平的
333 这个是平的打掉
后面这里又 又打掉一次
所以這裡好幾次其實都沒有什麼賺賠
然後呢 行情出去了
回來 在這個互換我先用3來測試
測試好像OK 然後再加一個55
結果呢 後面-16又虧掉了
後面仍然在這個水平繼續測試一次
然後就沒有了
然後呢 注意看喔
有同學說我打聖誕樹我反而放很大給大家看
我在这个地方测试打掉以后
我并没有一路往下摊平
注意看我完全没有往下摊
我们讲圣诞树的概念是指
例如说打单停损
打单停损
例如说光这几根停损一次
停损两次
停损三次
是这样连续的往下吃下来
然后一直被打掉
这个才叫做圣诞树
那我又回归到最原始的概念啦我从这边来刚才有同学说我吃在四五对不对对吧太厉害了就是这边那注意看哦
我并不是在
在这根的前面
K棒还很凶的时候就吃在这
我是吃在这个的边界上
那等一下我会
跟大家讲我在这边下单的想法
你们慢慢听
你说老鱼没有标准图
等一下我把图推开来
你就看得很清楚
然后呢我这样上去了
在这个地方我先减3
减3出在23328
328大概在
这附近反正就是喷出了
我还没有晚上开盘
突然间喷出好吧不然
缩回来好了随便出一下
意思一下
然后呢剩下的单子就继续在成本嘛
然后后面我们往后走
有同学吃在7.35这边
吃在这里
对吧
我刚好看到有同学说吃在这
来你看一下我到什么时候才吃
我到这里
这段过程中我其实待在电脑前面
我在一边玩游戏
然后一边眼睛瞄着盘面
这边我并没有吃
喷上去的我也没有吃
反而是这个回来了
后面这段我带你看一下我的EK
看一下这里
来
放大
我吃在
注意看哦
什么意思
我看着这一根
这个是加码哦
这不是新仓哦
这是加码
但是你看我的加码的动作
我在很末端的地方等它下来
下来以后下来以后
有没有破
照道理讲这边要直接连续性的这样
一路下去
结果我看到一个我熟悉的东西
咻的拉上来
然后我吃在哪里331
331在哪里
这里是330嘛
所以我吃在这里
如果要健身肠
等一下讲
等一下
那注意看我的动作
这是在1K对不对
但是其实我不是看着1K的单子
我们来到5K
5K的概念注意听我讲
概念
不是完整的標準圖
但是就是那個概念是
好多個5K的低點這樣看比較準好多個5K的低點例如說从7点多喷出以来又有一个小互换的低点
这个平面经历了我看一下
2到3个小时
有到2到3个小时吗
你看没有一个多小时
都没有跌破
打破的瞬间缩回来
你懂我的意思吗
我在这个地方我仍然在最边界
而且这个边界我习惯等他整理
以后我才加
加部位以后我的防守就从这边我就拉上来
这样子
那我加的这个部位我并没有
我并没有放很大
因为我也不希望我的均价快速的这个拉上来
这样知道这个想法吗
然后你说这个算不算边界二
算 但是他不容易找到
就刚刚好的边界二
可能三分K有吧
我不知道我们测试一下
可能三分K
有啦三分K
大概在这个的隔壁这里
但是你不需要为了
为了找到某一个格局的K棒的边界二
然后去刻意的选择哪一个
哪一个那个这样子
这样
那我是因为我做很习惯
而且又是加码单 我没有差
这样可以理解吗
那我当时加码以后
我心里想的是好啊
了不起就被打掉啊
我在这之前我其实还亏317
对吧
如果被打掉好了
用个300
384打掉了好了
今天赚70几块
美国开盘
那开盘后能怎么样再说了
就被打掉了
对吧
那目前
我跟大家说
我退一步看
你就会很清楚的看得到我在干嘛
来
我们先退到15k
退到15k
我刚刚的那几个单子
尤其是最下面的那个单子
我再赌的就是赌这个
60分
对不起
15k的这一根
照道理讲
隔壁的15k要继续的这样子
咻的往下走
应该往下
而且盘中其实往下杀过
有却没有杀
这对我来讲这是一个很棒的边界
好那我再退一步看来我们看一下30k你能看到刚好这条绿色的我的成本线你是不是可以慢慢理解我在干嘛了
哦原来这个边界是
是从昨天到现在的这个边界
哦
小10k应该也都是同一件事
所以我都是在k棒的偏下缘
但是我没有一次就吃到这个单子
我是
我是中间花了一些成本
那这些成本还在我可以控制的范围内
然后可能试单这样子
前面的那些试单
其实我一方面是人在外面拿手机试
而且我知道我错过早上
心里面有那个
就不爽的那个感觉
因为通常我早上那个时间
其实我会在盘前
那为什么今天没有
今天我们家小的生病在家
有人说改今天直播通常都有蛮好的边界
那有没有人知道为什么我现在的单
我不打算直接出场
我为什么要跟他凹下去
有没有人知道为什么
现在8点53分
理论上这根K棒
剩7分钟而已
应该不至于整个缩回去
所以假设这根K棒停这样子
对嘛
我难得做在60k的边界区域
那如果我这个单子还是只做个5分K短短的一点点
不是很浪费吗
对吧
这样都懂那个想法了
那你说右边的边界比左边你是指这个吗
在我的脑袋里面
曾经这里有个互换
这个互换跟这个支撑
这几个东西刚好就是这条绿色的边界
在我的脑袋里面
它就是这一区
注意看
区域
我们今天先从这边开始聊进去
就是我需要大家去理解一件事情
价格并不是用一个精准的一条线
准准准的那个价格来交易的
市场是活的
越短的刻度
它也是会有一个有点厚
厚度的区间只是那个区间会小一些
越大的刻度它的区间越宽越广
但是就是那个刻度在做的事情
好不好
这样
那
所以你切到60k你是不是可以一目了然知道我在干什么应该很清楚
好那刚好像看到我同学说早上那个地方来来来
早上现在
刚刚有一个同学说他看到这个5分k这个
想要空他大概那时候大概k棒在这里
我跟你说像这样子的空
还不是一个惯性对自己有利的空
假设是5K
因为我用涂鸦的角度来看
涨多跌少当时顶多到这里
你怎么知道下一次是继续涨多呢
还是怎么样
所以如果你要做空
你好歹也等这边
等这边
这下来以后变得跌多
涨少以后的这里
这个地方再来做会比刚刚那个点空来的好
不过的确现在有点上不去 这倒是真的
那早上的点 来来来
早上第一个 如果你有在习惯翻亚当的
跌破这边这一段到这一段的距离
来一秒钟请告诉我 一秒钟是不是刚刚好
对吧 那刚刚好 我涂鸦给大家看
我们用一个1分k的涂鸦
在这一段大喷
这是七点多的大喷
我们回到早上
早上这个有点扯
而且图好美
我只能这样讲
来
今天
今天的那个课程
其实要讲什么时候落底
然后什么时候可以吃
对不对
刚好用这个1分k
借我当案例
我们把这个案例学起来以后
你可以拿去放在
各個刻度你放在日線跟週線我都歡迎
只是你要等的時間週期
1分K可能等個10跟1分K
那日線就是等個10個日線或10週
看你用哪一種
那來注意看前面這段下沙
下沙上來下沙上來下沙上來
有哪一個地方有漲多跌少
我就問你啊
早上GC也很美沒錯
没有吧那这里是不是跌多涨少跌多涨少少、跌多漲少還在跌多對吧好仔細看這邊隔壁這根這裡
誒
我們看到那個慣性
塗鴉的慣性搭配上後面光1K的慣性
我們看到慣性不一樣
所以從這三分鐘以後
你心裡要有一個底
什麼底
市場怎麼樣
涨破一个本来这一段圈起来的地方
涨破一个本来涨不上去的点
有看到这件事吗
所以回来如果变成涨多跌少
在某个点你就可以测试
可能在这里
反正这些点都是我们常见的
例如说破底翻的点
或是上去以后回来的互换点
对吧
那后面当然大家都知道了
来
后面刚回来出现这个
哇上不去
好等他杀杀杀杀杀杀
这一根
这一根如果我有看盘
这一根的隔壁这里
我一定按亏钱我都会按
因为这一根是这个小互换
哎呦市场好像回来哦
有没有看到
那老玉这边有没有撞墙
有
所以我不会下大
我再赌
赌看看什么市场是不是对的
好
然后这个隔壁
这附近
你看
所以我刚刚是不是计划好了
是不是在原来在地底下
我就计划好了这样子
你懂这种想法吗
那这件事情注意看
我们的标准图有两个
一个是上去后回来的互换
那这个互换是不是跟这个一样
所以我最喜欢的是
那个你看
回来整理
跌破整理以后的边界
然后用这个角度再回来看我刚刚刚刚刚刚
来
要空对不对
这边是更好的空点对吧
来这边回来看我刚刚讲的
我说我5K回来的这个点
有没有看到互换
整理
用力的破
那个用力我很喜欢
包含像现在
前面越用力
但是后面突然间没力
男生们知道吗瞬间白米冲刺冲完了你就没力了对不对就是那种感觉我之所以讲男生是因为男生比较常在运动场跑步
是这样子好不好
来
那个
眼前现在如果刚刚有做到空单的同学
那
你要抱着跟我对坐也OK啊
那但是我不想要
现在
再告訴你說現在要做多或做空
現在不適合
現在全部卡在中間
這樣好不好
來
那
這個我就先放在這邊
因為剛剛好像我前面有看到同學在聊天
有聊到
聊到什麼
買大樹的
的大姐
聊投資
買了大樹
變成一棵大樹
好
我們看一下你的東西
我們看一下股票
股票在哪里
这边
大树金宝这是你刚刚的第二次
我看一下这一只
我先看这个好了
你说的这个
三张22手20出场26
来来来
你这样子是10%的风险
对吧
我想问你的是
你吃22理论上
你在赌的是这个边界就不要破
对不对
那如果你在赌这个边界不要破
其实今天就破掉了
不是吗
对吧
那而且我在猜你是今天吃的
因为你吃22前几天并没有22的位置
只有今天才有
对吧
所以呢
你今天吃22
我跟你说这不是一个好的进场
为什么来
先遮住
今天假设都还没有开盘
一大早长这样子
请问在开盘前你看到什么东西
你看到什么
上面斜斜的下面平平的
只要你在前一根今天都不算
前一根你看到这样
就知道今天往下再杀下去的几率偏高
好不好
你一定要记得这件事
而且请问你前一天是不是一个长上影线下杀的K棒
不只这样子前面几天是不是
哇很多这种下杀的样子都一路下来
所以其实今天本质上我不觉得是一个
适合吃
什么时候适合吃
来假设有一个这样子的K棒假设今天盘中杀下去今天盘中杀下去结果中间不知道什么时候,某个人把他救回来
你今天都还没有下单,但是你看到了收盘变成这样子的K棒
就这个,那你要很开心
因为这就代表隔壁这边有大户在做
我就跟着这些大户一起做
好不好
所以这个动作我认为
其实在吃单之前就不是很好
那第二个
我在猜你想要赌的
应该是赌这个边界
如果是这样有几种做法
是假设你是吃在前一天
隔天一破
其实就直接跑
这个边界很明显就没有效
就直接跑
另外一个是
你说你要赌20块
不要破
20块现在还不在萤幕上
20块在这里
你吃22到20
这其实坦白讲有点远
这已经不是这个刻度在做的事情
而且也没有标准图了
好不好
所以你说小部位做测试
你至少至少要等到
我刚刚讲的这个
这个十字线出现以后
再来做小部位测试
至少要等这个
这样可以吗
那大树我们看一下
你说观察64 69
来大树最近在观察
好来这个观察请你一秒钟画出两条线
它没有到很好的标准图
好不好
它就是两条线在这个地方
包含周线也是
所以不用急
你等它干嘛
来跌多长少
跌多目前还在长少当中
你等他有某一根长多以后
长多以后再回来的跌少
这时候再来上车
可能是这里
我还不知道
总之你至少等这个出现以后
再来上车会好多了
那你会说老鱼那前面这边
老鱼这里有长多
有啊
长多不应该吃
隔壁来
凶不凶
很凶人
结果没有出现我们要的停顿
要停顿至少要长这样
要长在这个地方
结果都没有
好不好
来那我就往后看一下
来自香港
昨天终于鼓起勇气
在增仓黄金
输了10万元中的三分之二
等一下
10万港币吗
10万的三分之二
如果是昨天到现在代表你做了一天
然后输掉了三分之二的资金
这位网友
拜托
请立刻停单
因为一天而已
你就可以把十万输掉三分之二
肯定有哪里不对
或是好多地方都不对
这不是鼓起勇气的问题
请你现在鼓起勇气停单
因为你现在满脑子想的
应该都是可以把刚刚的亏损
就今天的亏损
或是昨天的亏损给赚回来
现在要停单是要有勇气的
那我们这边给你很多勇气
但是真正要停下来的人
还是你自己
拜托停
那停了以后能怎么做
这问题有点多
我没有办法一句话讲完
但是很明显你放太多的钱去承受那个风险
太多了
或是过度交易也不一定
好不好
那你要感谢老天爷
感谢老天爷让你
现在亏了可能6万亏了7万
那我们趁机用这6、7万
至少不是6、70万
用这6、7万来学一个教训
然后感谢老天也教你这个功课
我们先来聊今天的东西
旁边同学要问的股票
我们待会再继续聊一下
今天的这个主题
其实会一直大量的回到股票
带大家看所以大家不用担心
OK
那我们就来聊这个股灾落底的迹象
最近
这样讲好了
最近市场上面各种消息满天飞
一下是战争一下是油价
之前的关税好像已经变得不是多重要的事情
对不对
那
现在的不确定性其实高于过去的以往的各种事件
因为
因为尤其是战争这种东西
然后你说原油一下子要涨涨很多一下子就跌很对吧,现在也很难判断什么时候落底,千万不要自作主张
去分析说,我跟你说,川普会怎么样,会怎么样
然后就会落底,我跟你说怎么样怎么样会落底
不要用你自己的个人的想法去分析也好,猜测也好
未来的行情不需要
现在的基本面什么东西全部是没有意义的
因为战争一下去
我举个例子好了
苹果的股票,AMD的股票,NVIDIA的股票
明明不是他战争
战争其实坦白讲跟他无关
但是这些股票为什么会涨会跌呢
他们的业绩有瞬间因为这样子受影响吗
没有
但是群众的情绪是会受影响的
这样好不好
所以现在都是失灵的状态
那反而最直接的是什么
是我们今天看到的价格动态
所有东西都失灵哦
但是价格动态是真的
大家记不记得川普
在那个他有一天在
在应该是美国
美国开盘前
他们的早上七点多
突然间宣布说什么
战争好像要结束怎么样
然后急喷一大根
一堆空袋被尬爆
记得那天吗
有人去找出
在那根急喷之前有新闻
或是有网路上有讨论
算大家自己找
在急喷的那根的前面有大量吃在底下
那个图形就是料大了
料大有吃到那根
底下的那个图形很明显就是下不去
你自己回去看
懂吗
所以我们的东西已经怀源到最根本最根本最根本了
了解这个想法
最根本的角度就是
就算有人先知道川普等一下要讲话
他还是会按进去
他按进去就不会跌
只要他按的量够就不会跌
人家又大量又把那个单子吃掉就不会跌
我就跟他就一定会出现我们讲的落底的迹象
好不好
David你有吃到对不对
那个很棒
我在讲什么很棒可能开车开太多了会大舌头不行来先来到云霄飞车
这是我前几年去日本
横滨那边巴景岛水族馆游乐园
它是水族馆加游乐园一起的云霄飞车
它是盖在海边
所以你是坐出去
然后绕来绕去然后才回来
然后呢
注意看
我底下这句话
我说什么样子的轨道
来什么样子的轨道
会让云霄飞车减速
市场就像云霄飞车
例如眼前的这个
眼前的这个就是云霄飞车
如果
我们还原到前面
各位看这边
看这边
看这里
眼前的涂鸦
这个涂鸦本身
就是一个云霄飞车的轨道
如果一个云霄飞车
走在这个涂鸦上面
它这一段过程
它的速度是最快的时候
还最慢的时候
应该最快吧
你去那个利保乐园玩那个断轨
下来是90度直接下
最快就是这种
是吧
好
再来哦
他有没有变缓
这里有一段冲上去平的
然后在上面绕一圈
然后来到这里下来
下来以后
有没有看到
所以这里是最快的
所以是一个行情
刚好这里也有
一个市场要从下跌变成上涨
以前他的走的坡度
那个缓和的感觉
要先出来
所以你就可以在涂鸦上面
本来是跌多涨少的涂鸦
涂鸦上面看得出来
这个市场不一样了
包含刚刚的这个
刚刚的1K
我们切到1K去看
1分K
1分K有够标准
来来来
本来的市场这么凶
这么凶
对吧
那注意看我拉
我把这个放大一点好了
注意看我拉
看这边
有没有看到有没有看到这是我们常见的什么东西破底翻的图对吧所以一个市场要从下跌转上涨以前
你自己看有没有要经过这个地方
这样你懂我的意思吧
这在一分可以通用在刚刚同学的股票来
同学的股票这一支是大树就刚刚讲的大树
所以眼前的这个云霄飞车有
其实有点变缓慢有
但是这个云霄飞车的轨道什么时候会往上弯
我还不知道
我还需要一些比较明确的样子来做确认
不然眼前就是在这种地方鬼魂
但是他有没有缓下缓和下来了
有
刚刚我同学问到2330
台积电跟以往的
的股票不太一样
台积电的跳空其实蛮多的
因为他还有我们讲的夜盘
在美国那边的ADR
所以其实如果你去看美国那边的ADR
其实它的现行连续很多
来我这边调查一下
在前几周就听到我在讲说上面这些台积电不要乱吃
不要乱追的举手
我一直一直一直在跟大家提醒
然后但是有人就是讲不听
你知道吗
就是我也没有办法
甚至我還記得台積電有某一天在這上面
我還跟大家說各位這邊什麼區
滿族區
我們苦口婆心的講大家都不理我
然後一堆人在這邊發文說
耶兩千塊五百萬進場
然後說要當傳家寶
有啦你說有沒有可能這樣上去
靠後面這什麼鬼啊
怎麼會有後面
好对吧
所以我们一直讲了老半天了
但是你知道吗
在二月底三月初这一段
是我在网路上看过最多最多人
在讲说要去借钱来定来存股的时候
最多人讲的
就是我随便划
可能是因为演算法的关系吧
我可能看的其中一篇
他就一直推类似给我
这样好多人都在
2月底3月初甚至整个2月都觉得好像农历年
那就拼命的去借钱然后来压压压
有没有搞错你压在台积电在这种时候的地方
拜托
Please
我也很认同台积电是护国深山
但是你不用买在2000块啊
是吧
然后呢
最近开始出现一些
当初买的人开始在烦恼
说我的单子怎么办
台积电还会上涨吗
台积电这里可以吃吗
来我就问你啦
眼前的台积电
最近的台积电走势跟美股的走势
好像又不见得一样了
来看一下
上面斜斜的
下面平平的
按照我们过去的经验
这个后面往下跌的几率蛮高的
所以你说什么时候适合进场
哪一天台积电出现这种可以棒
截图一下
像这样子
某一天
假设明天在这
或是最好在这里
如果可以的话
先破底到1750
杀破一些
然后或是这样子
反正如果有破底是超棒的
这样
然后你看这个地方
如果有这样子
这一根以后的隔壁的台积电超美丽
要防守又很简单
要进攻也很简单
对吧
进可攻退可守的位置
要错我风险就这样子
要对我有这样子的利润可以赚
这不是好很多吗
而这个交易的模式
有没有跟我刚刚短线里吃小娜
小娜
我说的是这个
这里
最一开始讲解过的地方有点像
我的概念就是在那个边界的最下缘
好
再来
所以云霄飞这个概念
请你随时摆在眼前
那你看刚刚云霄飞是不是来到这边
涨多跌少
应该要涨多
结果没有涨多
然后就跌下来
对不对
注意看
应该要涨多
走平了
然后就掉下来
所以其实市场就是同样的逻辑
一直在循环
就算你问我一些
我从来没有在看的期货
我也一样用价格走势讲给你听
因为原油可能不一样
黄金的组成一桶原油
是多少我也不知道
这不重要那个价格走势是全世界通用的放在鸡蛋放在高粒菜的价格对全部都通用只要它有价格我就可以判断
判断它的高低
判断哪里下不去上不去
好不好
来
同样是盘整
发生在哪个位阶差很多
要我看技嘉
是哦
来来来技嘉
技嘉技嘉
我还记得
对对对
对啊
季家现在回来
但是他回来的样子
本周今天来周二
有点凶
所以你要干嘛
你要干嘛
等
等他在这边停顿
今天礼拜二嘛
三四五
你还有三天的时间
扣掉一天要放假
你还有两个交易日的时间
你至少至少至少
至少在这里等到一个这样子
等到K棒由大根K棒变成
注意看下沙的大根K棒要涨以前的K棒是不是都小小根的
你仔细看一下
你可以把我今天讲的这句话拿到任何刻度
任何股票任何期货
一个下沙很凶的K棒都是很大根的
所以一个行情要从下沙转上涨以前
中间的这个整理
K棒会变得小小根
实体实心地方小小的
然后开始长一些上下引线
这样好不好
所以等哦
不要急哦
如果隔壁继续往下刹破了
你就不要理它了
刹破你就等
等什么
如果它要拉回来
如果它刹破又拉回来
隔壁这样子
好东西
这是我们过去做很久以来的
好东西的这种感觉
等 现在不是适合
来让我把这个观念讲完
同样是盘整
什么意思
假设原来的行情是这样子
看我现在要乱画
假设行情是这样子
在这个地方发生盘整
来 请问你
这个位阶在已知的行情的上中下
我不知道未来是往哪里走
我讲的是已知的行情
是不是很简单
上 中 下
对吗
所以这个盘整发生在这边对做多来讲不是很有利因为它发生的位阶大颗度的位阶
不对
我们刚刚不是有看到
例如说这里技嘉日线
这是不是有一天两天三天
三天都在248附近鬼混对吧
它发生的位阶发生在
前几次都上不去的地方
有没有
是吧
那既然它发生在这个地方
这个盘整
老于老于这里啊
涨多跌少
哇有下影线啊
不行
因为它的位阶不对
对大格局来讲
所以我刚刚才会说
说在这个地方
如果发生这个东西
在这里整理的起来
这对多头是有利的
因为它在大颗度的上中下的哪边偏下缘
然后的小格局整理起来
我们来到现在的小那
来
一样意思我们用
5K好了这样
这样子给大家看好了
注意看哦
我们来到来到来到来到
60K
各位看我的60k
你现在知道我在这边做多的概念吧
这样图一看很清楚对不对
请问现在是在60k的上中下
哪里现在现在在这里
是不是偏上
所以我就知道大颗度偏撞墙
所以短颗度
短颗度在这边的任何多单
我在5k里面
这边的多单都不好下单
因为它在大科度的上中下的哪里
上
可以理解吗
然后台子5K现在是不是标准图
好我们借由这个同学问的东西来看一下
台子7 5K我们来看一下
标准图
等一下问我标准图的同学
你对于标准图的概念有问题
为什么呢
你是要问做多还是做空
不管哪一个都不对来做多的标准图有两种一种是这个破底翻一种是这个破底翻然后我把它用半透明我对过去
没有啊
没有一样的东西啊
看不出来啊
另外一种是是互换
互换
我把这个也对过去
你说5K嘛
也也
你如果是标准图
你要讲的是这里吗
是这个吗
如果是这么大的宽度这样子
那这已经不是5K的事情
来我把它拉到旁边去
来到小10K
小10K这个边际也没有到很美
15K
勉强接受
大概
也没有到很美
坦白说
但是
当我们在讲标准图的概念
来我这边讲一个很直接的东西
我需要在最近期的连续图形出现标准图
注意这句话哦
我需要在近期的连续图形
就是过去这可能我看一下
两三个小时内他需要出现这个
所以如果刚刚底下这边的这个地方
他稍微下来一点点跑到这里
然后如果这样子
如果我们来拼图一下
这个低一点点
然后这个也整块更低
看我的行情
上来这边
走上去走下来
走上去走下来这里
如果你是在这个时间点
问我说老鱼这里是不是标准图
那我会给你过
好吗
那你说老鱼我问的是空方
好,来来来,空方反过来,比对
比对
没有啊,我对不出来啊
没有,没有一样啊
有没有
我看不出来空方标准图啊
你懂我意思吗
哦对,如果是这个地方
位置对不对
要看,要看那个
假设刚刚有这个
这个这个
我会在这个时间往回头看一下
当时的60分k是不是一个60k渐渐的在这里
你这样听得懂我的意思
有这个意思吗
我现在怎么找
例如说
例如说这个这个我们看这边
假设我隔壁这边要下单
我先不管短线
我也先不管撞不撞墙
这个是另外一件事情
我们先把焦点先说回来
我只是要讲一个很简单的概念是
我要下单的左下角
有没有60分K的这个东西在帮我撑腰
你懂我意思吧
我要先包含这个
这里这个左下角有这种东西
那这我会比较甘愿一点
那你说老鱼这里有啊
也对如果是我看到这边的隔壁这里
我一样会下单
那这个就会被打掉
打掉错了
但是我不会大错
我不会错一个很远的这样子
好不好
所以例如说看前面的60K长这样
后面容易下来
60K长这样子后面容易下来
这样可以吗
好来
所以再回来聊
我们刚刚的讲解有没有很清楚
我需要那个整理发生在大科度的上中下的哪里
中间的整理我也不理它
因为它就是上有压下有撑
我需要这个动作发生在下缘
而且注意哦
有破底以后的下缘
我才可以在这个框框内看到破底翻
这样可以吗
我需要这个
需要在这个地方
所以这个地方的左边最好
它就是有一个点两个点
所以你回来看我刚刚的小纳
刚好今天就是有这个案例
来我打开我下单的位置
加码了这个
其实这个也是
这个也是
我前面的单子
我已经整个讲过
在今天直播的最前面
所以后面进来的同学
你等一下直播结束以后
再回去前面看
好不好
我要讲的是这个
注意看这个
这个我看一下
这个边界被这个东西这样打很凶的打破
超级凶啊
所以照道理讲要继续凶狠下去
这样好吗
所以我看到它下去回来不知道有没有办法切更短的15秒我切15秒的目的我只是要看一下有沒有辦法看到
有有有來來來來
來
因為剛剛在1K裡面你只看到我在1分鐘K
1分鐘K然後看到一個下影線回來吃
有沒有看到我吃在這一根
這一根的前面我是不是看到這個東西
这个已经是15秒k 我没有要做到那么短
我只是要告诉大家 我是看到他下价格
懂 回来 懂那种感觉吗
我只是在做这件事情 我其实很爱
所以在边界的时候 我常常都是在旁边这样看
当坏人 当那个
嘿嘿,趕快前面吃多單的人,趕快停損,等你停損
一個一個停損,一個一個停損,停損
然後停損下去咻回來,哈哈我的
懂嗎?我們在市場上都在當壞人
這樣可以嗎?
好的,那個要花錢買好像一個月多少?
39美金的樣子
對了,如果你要買那個報價
我其实没有在看十档挂单
有人会看我没有在看
我只是不喜欢看到他就是只有一个点这样子
我喜欢看到有很多挂单这样子
我比较安心
如果只有最前面的挂单看起来就觉得好单薄
我看不到那个价差的那种感觉
那他的扣款日是每月的一号
所以假设你是像今天3月31号才开这个功能
你今天会被刷卡一次
然后你4月1号就是明天
你还会被刷卡一次
所以你要就是每个月的1号
去使用它那个
即时的10档报价的那个服务
其实严格说起来超过10档
自己看这个已经不止10档
我已经划很远了
我也不知道为什么他可以开给我这么多
反正就买了然后就有了
就这样子 超多的 好不好
好了 我们不要看15秒 我没有要看15秒 好不好今天我我们看得懂,那我要讲不行的来,一样,同样的两条线
大科度的行情
这样子,这样子,这样子,这样子
好,破底了
来到这里,结果在这个地方
出现了
这个
请问你
圈起来的地方的多单
好不好做
圈起来这个
答案是不好做
经过刚刚的讲解
你应该很清楚知道
但是有没有可能就这样上去
有啊
但是如果你是新仓要进场
它不好进场
因为你就是那个带着钢盔
跟着撞
撞最上面这个很坚固成墙的人
可能这一次会撞得上去
可能撞不上去
我不知道
但我不是那个勇者
我都让别人
让小Lolo
Sla
去当勇者
我们老大都要坐在后面的
你看那个复仇者联盟
我每次都会讲
Thanos他都是叫那些小兵
去前面先打仗
你说他是英雄吗
屁啦
他最后一个才出来
他哪里是英雄
前面的都死光才轮到他
对吧
真正的英雄应该是像美国队长一样
有英雄光环怎么打都不会死
冲第一个这才叫英雄
没有
真实世界请各位当那个老大
躲在后面放冷箭的老大
要死给别人死
要冲上去你跟着赚
冲不上去你没事
就像现在的小娜一样
现在的小娜
上去
这时候我就会教大家赶快去买多单
快点快点做多
想到要冲
要冲死是别人的事情
像现在9点半了
有成交量进来开盘了
冲
这些冲的人
现在买在430的人
我帮他祷告一下
对啊
可能冲得上去
冲上去了
但是我的成本对不起
我的成本在底下
这不是很棒吗
各位懂吗
如果冲不冰
来来来
哇哇哇冲了一次留了一个上影线冲了两次可能又要留一个上影线如果连续两个上影线在这边后面第三个后面就往下掉的几率就高很多
但是现在已经越来越看到有人开始在卖
所以我跟着冲在这边很笨啊
好不好 请眼前的各位都练习当那个在后面
拿着小刀就好了
的那个老大
你看刚刚冲430的人
我帮他祷告
结果我祷告失败
他已经挺顺
对不对
好不好
不要乱空
现在瞬间这样子
不要乱空乱多
他航星跳太快了
不要理他
你就切开一段时间这样就好
好不好
来来来
所以我们要看
发生在哪个位阶差很多
然后旁边同学有说Tesla
好耶Tesla来
Tesla来
放大一点给大家看
这是我的成本
几乎要达到我的成本
几乎要达到
那各位
他是不是在互换的边界
本周是不是出现
上一周出现这么凶狠的这一周
隔壁有没有破
有破但是照道理讲
前一周这么凶
本周理论上要直接下来
把我打到成本
让我不赔出场
应该要这样子
但是却没有
所以各位
特斯拉的概念
你来到小科度
你一定会看到我刚刚讲的
尤其是像今天
来今天
跌多涨少
跌多
在昨天
昨天的深夜都还是跌多
涨少
跌多
今天
今天一开那个电子盘一开就长多变成什么
来356这里
请问这条线是不是我们本来的压力变成什么东西
紫层然后就回来了
然后就长上来
坦白讲我一点都不压抑
好不好
那有要吃的人可以开始了
這些位置是周線的上中下哪裡
我不知道各位還記不記得
在特斯拉480块500块这附近
那时候出现了好多篇说木头姐
大家知道木头姐是谁吗
美股的议员很厉害的
总之说什么
然后还有网路上很多人都说
对不起木头姐不是议员
议员那个叫做裴洛西
有很多特斯拉
然后什么网路上那个木头姐就说
特斯拉上看多少
800还1000
反正那一段时间全美国的人
大家都觉得特斯拉要涨上去
如果大家有印象
在去年底的新闻
请你自己回去Google一下
好不好
就从这边然后到这里
我还记得当天我还提醒很多人
我说特斯拉大家都这里差不多了
对吧
你买在480
很闷啊
你要买不如买在这种地方
这不是好很多吗
上中下
OK
还有
既然有大颗度了
我们刚刚大颗度了
大颗度这里
我们说大颗度的上中下
对不对
你需要去看到
我们刚刚讲的这个
用小朋友去涂的感觉去涂鸭
我们今天前面做过很多次
对不对
你涂鸭以后你就会亲眼看到那个惯性
回来还是没有回来
而且你會看到一個很特別的現象
叫做K棒會變小
那這個東西我叫做原地停頓
我旁邊同學要看2388好
我們就剛好拿這個2388來當案例
來
我們看日線
我不知道為什麼我都會出現這樣
應該只有這樣而已
我的萤幕27而已啊
我左右两个萤幕都是27
我就只有两个萤幕
坦白讲来到周线一看
前一周长这样子
本周仍然是这样子的K棒
我觉得
没有很美
主要是前面这边太凶了
这样好不好
所以他回来到这个地方来我们来看什么叫K棒变小这根K棒是不是很大这根K棒的实体K棒也仍然很大你说老鱼K棒实体K棒小小的
但是它产生了一个比较麻烦的事情
它带着长长的上影线
在我的荧幕里下沙是红色的
所以请看一下前面这根K棒
来做空的力量是从最高价一直到收盘价
做空的能力有这么长
这么长一段
做多只有下面这一小小的那个下影线
对吧
那同样的道理
这根收盘价在这边
但是做空的力量有这么多
这么多
做多的力量从这边到这边
有了比较有多单的
但是好像
好像没有完全的压回去
所以你心中就要有个底了
这两天的这个日线
其实不用太急
你可以在底下这个水平
48到50块这中间
轻松的去等他
因为这边也太靠哪里
太靠前面各种上不去的地方
所以眼前的K棒虽然变小
但是他还没有真的
真的变得很棒
好不好
我们喜欢的原地停顿
大概是像这种概念
来这个
这一根的这种原地停顿的概念
如果发生在隔壁这一天
出现这样子
这就是例如说
今天一大早是这个价格
是51块
然后中间涨涨涨涨涨涨涨
收盘还是回来51
停顿了
那这个概念可以放在一天
也可以放在一个礼拜
它需要原地停顿
那原地停顿的K棒
如果压缩的越扁
实体K棒越扁
其实是好事
因为K棒越扁代表价格过度集中
也不是过度
很集中
这个是好事
懂吗
但是我不要这样子
我不要
像这个
假设这个地方出现这样子的K棒
引线长长的
实体K棒扁扁的
哇那其实没有什么意义
这个是不是就是我们刚刚讲的
上边界所以虽然有下乙线出现了但是他出现的地方在上边界所以这根不适合吃
这样听得懂那个意思吧
好不好
我们再来看同学说NVIDIA
来NVIDIA
这边直接叫比较快
来NVIDIA周线
哦,来来来来来,周线是个很好的案例
请问周线是不是一个很长,从9月哦
从什么时候,2025、9月
所以2025的9月到现在的周线有没有破
很凶有没有破
请问今天礼拜二本周有没有拉回来
这里
哦
那这个是一个很棒的讯号
因为K棒由大大大K棒变成什么
小K棒
所以这周你不用急
这个先忽略
不要理他不用急这样好了
是不是我的系统要重灌
不是我说这个
好改天改天要把这个移除
重装一下这个这个TradingView的这个软体好了
总之这一周在这附近
都在刚刚的周线的那个十字线的范围内
懂吗
170也好
168也好
这些地方是很美丽很美丽的边界
甚至有人在吃QQQ
如果你是现在要去吃QQQ的
它也是第一次周线出现这样
所以我不知道大家知不知道
我今天
特别是今天讲这个
古灾落底迹象
给大家的用意是什么
懂吗
我已经很故意挑在这个时间点讲了
希望大家听得懂
好不好
这个可遇不可求
因为刚好又有直播
而且现在直播又是礼拜二
是说这一周如果就长这样子
真的很漂亮
好吗
來小娜
EK正在撞 現在小娜EK很醜啦
不用特別去管EK這樣
你就先這樣子就好了 好不好我平常交易的時候其實我會把那個拿掉因为我觉得那个很臭我不喜欢看到画面这样子乱七八糟的
这样画面干净多了
有同学问到我的书
我的书名坦白讲书名我还没有取
书名是个很麻烦的东西
那眼前我要赌的东西
我要堵的东西
现在9点42
前一根说回来
但是这一根这样子
其实我说不定可以堵它一下
堵这个直播结束
说不定可以挂个这边
然后对吧
我可能可以这样子
我试试看
我们挂
这边
诶诶正在喷
诶正在喷
4500跟3000多
好像可以
好了再喷上去
我先出一些
那我跟妳講我的出場我可以這麼做
我現在可以這樣子
其實這邊賺差不多
例如說四口
這裡先出一個四口
好出了四口
然後把這邊剩下拉到這裡來
然後剩下的呢
剩下的我看一下60k我能在哪裡出
60k
好啦就這樣子
因為這個60k照道理講要出去
所以接下來這兩個小時
应该要涨斜斜的涨这样子
那如果没有就赚
最后这个就赚485
离开
如果有就赚个2900
就这样子
好不好
老鱼交易业好像可以
看到美股涨这样
马上去开IB
聪明
时间点很好
但是你不要说老鱼说可以买
就给我狂压什么的
我仍然会错
只是这个错的这个时间点
以及相对起人家当初买在上面的那些人来讲
我们已经好很多了
你的风险还是要守好
好不好
PLTR是不是还要再等等
我们看一下
PLTR
周线
的确还是要再等等
虽然这里是亚当满足的
也是一个小互换区域
但是因为昨天真的蛮凶的
你知道吗
NQ的进场位置
你可以明确的跟我讲说是我最
一开始的牡丹
还是刚刚的你看到的那个加码单
好不好
我等你
等你
等你讲这样
OK
一直以为没办法部分出
可以啊
可以部分出啊
对啊
现在回头看刚刚出了
没有部分出
你要直接出也可以啊
你看我出在23454
嘿嘿嘿
耶
呵呵呵
那你要出场你按这边也可以
你按这个也可以啊
按这里也可以出
这边是被我大头挡住了
对这里啦
这里也可以出
你按这个也可以出
或是直接在萤幕上面这样子也可以出
我要讲一下哦
来来来
我要讲一个东西是
如果你是在
萤幕的外面
例如说你是挂
挂一个
这个独立的卖单在外面
然后结果呢
假设行情是这样往下打下来
打到你的这个停利赚485
上面这个也会取消
但是这个独立的卖单
会悬空的
凭空就放在那边
所以这是很危险的事情
所以你离开之前
请你一定要把这个给关掉
这样好不好
换美金进IB
我没有想那么多
我真的没有想那么多
但是我不会在27块的时候
应该这样讲
现在我不会在台币31块的时候去换
之前可以用27块台币就换美金的时候
我那时候就换一堆了
你懂我意思吧
27跟31
这个价差还是有出来
所以我就不喜欢在31换
所以如果我还有剩余的美金可以用
我就不会换钱
除非我已经没有美金可以用了
我才会换
這樣
有人問黃金或是有人問
我均價的位置
我均價的位置不是
那是均價的
等一下喔
馬來西亞可以買到我的書嗎
這我好問書商耶
對啊
然後
我先看一下旁邊的同學問好不好
等一下我把我先結起來
同學講話有點快
截起來老魚前面的單一直被点掉为什么不会想说是做错边
我是做对还是做错
一点都不重要
我从来都不在乎我做对边还做错边
反正做错了
市场就把我打掉就好了
我只在乎眼前有没有我要的迹象
那我一直都在
都在这个边界
我都在这个60K跟15K的
这个大边界去测试
只要这个边界没有真的烂掉
我就是在这个边界测试
只是短线在哪里测试
这样子而已
好不好
细节在今天直播的最前面有讲到
我就不想浪费时间继续讲
这样
我那个箭头在这里
你按preference这里
然后有show chart execution
我是把它打勾就有,你取消就没有了
就这样子,我涂干净很多
好不好
来,那同学要看什么,6188
我看一下6188
6188,POTR今天的样子开始回来
刚刚看到这个K棒有回来的样子
6188你要问什么
6188可以看一下吗
来 问这个的同学
下一次你问的时候教你
你又要说老鱼6188我预计等破底番吃
还是你要告诉我你的计划
不能只是6188看一下
那这样我就看一下
8188就不讲了
没有啦 新同学我不会对你这么严厉
好不好
你需要自己先有一套计划
我才能告诉你你的计划
这样子是合理还不合理
不能只是叫我看
那我就随便讲就好了
对不对
来
那我就问大家
眼前的惯性
有任何我们刚刚前面讲的涨多跌少了吗
还没有
我可能到小时k都还没有
小时k
小时k第一次出现
关键边界跌破的十字线
所以除非在今天的最后两个小时
最后一个小时
你才看得到这件事情
所以你不用急
好不好
日線才剛開始
還沒還沒
好嗎
還沒還沒然後Uber的週線搭配日线我怎么看Uber的周线
周线是长期周线的下缘
上中下的下缘
而且这边还是上面翻下来的这种满足区也是这个
来这根翻亚当
这根
这个翻亚当下来
你看一下
差不多啊
就是这样满足区啊 对不对
所以满足区我觉得底下日线这里
这个日线吃在这里也算很聪明
因为这根是有破 破的应该要继续杀
隔壁没有继续杀 回来吃在这里
如果同学
同学吃在这个地方是很聪明的事
如果你吃前一根会被我吊起来打屁股
这根不行 隔壁这根很聪明
因为你拿前面这一个人的尸体
来当做当做什么
当做盾牌
我应该被停立了真的吗
没有啊我拉很远
好像有点上不去
看一下
还在喷
5k这样子还在喷
看一下
差900块
800随便出一出
好了 出一出
好 今天休息了
然后ATOM
周线3块附近等
周线
3块附近等
可能不见得等得到
因为这一周已经出现这样子的
代表这个下沙
前一周这么凶
是第一次出现周线的停顿
当然现在才礼拜二
可能345翻盘也有可能
但是如果本周五
周线还是涨这样
其实隔壁往这边的几率就高很多
这样子
好不好
你看同样的
之前追出去买在7块的
现在很哭啊
因为7块剩一半
真的打到3.5
買在7塊的然後打到3.5哭爆了
然後哭爆了然後就回來了
對不對好嗎來 SPCE突然间喷上去
离自己目标还没到
各位你看一下
我们今天很多案例都是什么
它在周线的上中下
甚至这个短短的周线也是一样
所以你要在这下面继续做空吗
不要
现在要做多吗
也不要
因为现在那个点都过了
你現在就是如果你底下有多單保證
沒有也沒關係
你就等這樣子
那我要講的是你看前一段時間
來畫出直覺的兩條線
你在這邊噴到這裡之前
你是不是早就知道這邊是4塊多5塊
就不要買在這
對吧
這樣OK嗎
当要停利时看到什么状况要直接出场
来
所有的停利都是直接出场
没有那个停利是这样子
假设我坐在这个地下
没有那个停利是等他回来
跌破某个均线
或是跌破某个支撑才走
你都已经要停利了
你等回来走干嘛
停利就是直接喷的走
就是这样
就是我预计的地方上来到了
那刚刚我为什么走
刚刚刚刚我觉得差不多了
因为我原本预计
我随便拉的点是2900
那2900刚刚我好像出在
大概赚2000亿的地方
差几百块
反正今天是赚的无所谓
这样子
怎么抓停地你知道吗
很简单
这一段
这根翻出去
这就是我刚刚的想法
我刚刚脑袋里大概就有这种感觉
可能这样子
结果我又是刚刚没有看Peter旁边那句话
我可能等一下就中我原来的那个停力
对不对
没关系啊
我欢喜甘愿
注意停力就是只有
就直接出掉
没有人在等回挡出的
那除非是例如说像我刚刚错过了
哎呀错过最佳停力点
然后可能回来一些
差不多了出
但是对我来讲
我还是很立刻就直接出一出的
就是这样
千万不要等什么回档出
好不好
IB我还没开始下M&Q
TQQ的单我开始在建
我是建在我自己的公司账号那边
我开始在建
然后那个M&Q我也还没开始做
这样
因为我不知道大家记不记得
我好像在上个礼拜直播说过
说常常会遇到
4月份我们清明扫墓的这个阶段
常常让我有一些多单的行情让我可以一路抱着
然后说不定就到六月去的
上礼拜直播大家应该记得这件事吧
讲到这个今天是台子旗的月底月初
来来来来趁机讲一下
趁机讲一下
有熟悉我的同学应该都知道
熟悉我的同学是什么
是我常常告诉大家台子期如果现在是每个月的月底月初
例如说三月二月底三月初或是二月底一月底二月初这种
如果这种边界很值得买选择权也好
或是做期货多单也好
或是你就买现货也好
我没有意见
反正很值得做它个十几天做到这个月的中旬
台湾有个惯性是他要喷
常常是前两周就直接喷到一个地方
那前面二三月这一段
这个很特别
他喷了一个月
这是很特别的事
很少这样子
那最近你在底下这边
你应该已经看到
这60k有够清楚
底下这里
对吧
所以遇到像这样子
这个60k在这种地方
你可以很
如果你有买到多单
很值得继续往四月的中旬那边度过去
这样OK吗
来下课前我看一下同学的这些问题
看影片练习没问题
真的好像乱了
练习的当下
要看你现在在练的是什么
因为每一个
等一下我把我把我的FB的我也有一篇文等一下等一下等一下等一下我在旁边找
等我一下
因为我有放那个
自己的
自我检讨的那个在哪里
我找不到了
等我一下
曾经被我列为
列为最前面的那个
那个文
但是现在我突然间找不到了
等一下
等我一下
我一定要把它叫出来
啊有了
我找出同学认证表
来
要看你是在
这是之前那时候我还有在帮同学改作业的时候的认证表
然后要看你现在是在哪一个阶段
什么意思
例如说你现在在练静态练习
那你的目标就是这些事情就好
你不要去管后面的事都不用管
然后如果你现在是在练边界乱打一
那你的目标就是直接
把所有的焦点摆在边界来了就乱打
接刀也可以
对哦 你看 我说接到也可以
然后如果你的目标 你现在在练的是边界乱打
二就是一定要左边有人挡子弹
我刚刚不是有在一只股票说
哪一只啊 忘记了
说前面有人挡子弹 有没有
你吃在隔壁
Uber啦 你吃在隔壁就很好 有没有
这样子 然后慢慢的吃在干净边缘
我今天的单子我都是练习
吃在干净边缘的概念
所以如果你有练到这个阶段
其实理论上我刚刚在打的东西你就都看得懂
接下来你要练的就是静态练习 练标准图
然后善用这个半透明的绝招
就是我们今天也玩过嘛
最一开始拿半透明的图在对在行情上
然后接下来这些都是静态
然后找出两条线
那你的问题应该是练习的当下
所以到动态练习的情形
你練習的情形 理論上你的前面都已經
前面各個階段的拼圖你都練過了
所以到了最後這個真正動態市場在動的時候的練习应该都已经比较完整了这样所以这些其实就是
就是我们在当初在带同学这样一路练下来的过程
这样子好不好
有同学说好希望我再开吗
我应该不会开呢
因为
IB到穷多单很棒啊很棒啊
因为真的好累
你知道吗 就是我这边讲一下
就是这跟一般的一般的
例如说外面的群组
有什么收费代单
有合格的老师那种
你知道收费代单我就反而简单反而就代
这里停损那里停利这样子
像我们这种改作业
我后来觉得我
我有点后悔开了这个先例就是
因为同学假设打了老于我打了10单20单
你帮我看一下我就一个个看
那改一张作业我就要跳进去他当时的图
想一下他当时在想什么
第二张第三张第四张
我都要进去到他的思考逻辑里面
然后又跳出来
然后想一下我能怎么帮他调
他现在到第几阶段
他缺的是什么东西
一个人的作业就可以耗掉很多很多的脑力
然后如果一次改个10个20个30个同学
我直接就摊在这里了
这样
然后所以那段时间我们一天24小时
我跟Jack还有廖大
我们三个人分三班在改作业
连晚上都有人帮你改作业这样子
但是我们每一次任何一个人值了其中一个班以后
剩下来的时间我们只想耍废
所以我的书在那个阶段
一个字都没有写
因为完全没力了
对
然后那时候很常这样就是
例如说我早上
假设我是只早上
我一坐完
我会直接回房间睡他个两个小时
因为整个人完全挂掉
所以书上其实也有这些
我就是在教你怎么去练习干嘛的
然后实战的经验有都有
包含关键边缘等等
还有一些故事也都有在里面这样好不好可以索取一份这個清單我記得有 只是我現在在FB裡面
如果在FB 我搜尋
你在我的FB裡搜尋看看
應該找得到才對
我找到我再把它
列為那個字頂貼文
好嗎
所以其實就是這些事情
很有梗
老鱼交易
我应该会把老鱼交易页
摆在某个显眼的地方
这个应该会放上去
这样好不好
有人找到了
很棒很棒
牡丹的位置
不会觉得那边有空方互帆的感觉吗
好问题
来回答完这个
我们就来准备来下课
哎呀我刚刚不应该看Peter的
没有啦
是我自己要出的
我不会怪你了
来我们来看一下
牡丹的位置
我最早的牡丹是从底下这里
你要问的是问这里吗
空方互换吗
你要讲的是这个对不对
好问题来来来
好问题
你讲的是应该是指
这个吧
这九口对不对
最一开始的这九口对吧
来
如果从这个角度看
请问是区间的上中下哪一个
区间的哪一个
下吧
对不对
好
区间的下源
窝窝躲在这个后面
这样
那你说空方互换
我们就可以把一个空方互换的图给画出来
空方互换长这样子
长这样
对吧
那
来
来哪里
你说老鱼这里啊
这里啊
这里是空方
互换啊
没有啊
这个绿色的图跟
跟这个图
有一样吗
我要的是这个位置跟这个位置
它要连在一起
它要碰到
这次稍微破一些都没关系
所以如果是在这里
如果在这里
你跟我说在这个附近
假设哦
假设假设
这边长了一个这样子的K棒
这里
这样子的可以吧
这根长在这里
然后你说这里出现这个地方的空方互换
那这个我让你过这根可以而且这边还是偏上
〔此段辨識失敗，約 1:20:00 起〕